[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann und
für guten abend auch von mir wir haben
unter anderem diese themen für sie
gelockerte quarantäne regeln und 2g plus
in der gastronomie bund und länder
beschließen neue maßnahmen gegen korona
schießbefehl gegen demonstranten in
kasachstan dürfen polizei und militär
und ohne vorwarnung das feuer eröffnen
und tod eine schauspiel legende sidney
porti erster schwarzer superstar in
hollywood stirbt mit 94 jahren
[Musik]
erstes bund-länder-treffen dieses jahres
um deutschland auf die drohende omikron
welle vorzubereiten kanzler scholz rief
erneut dazu auf sich impfen zu lassen
und masken zu tragen außerdem
verständigten sich die regierungs chefs
und chefinnen auf folgendes für die
gastronomie soll in ganz deutschland
zweig plus gelten also zutritt nur für
geimpfte und genesene mit zusätzlichem
test ausnahme dreifach geimpfte für sie
entfällt dieser nachweis und die
quarantäne regeln werden gelockert so
müssen etwa kontaktpersonen die einen
vollen impfschutz vorweisen nicht mehr
in quarantäne
alle anderen können sich künftig nach
sieben tagen frei testen andreas huppert
es war eine der kürzesten runden in der
geschichte der vielen corona gipfel im
kanzleramt keine drei stunden dauerte
der austausch zwischen der
bundesregierung und den ländern der
kanzler machte noch einmal deutlich das
wirksamste mittel im kampf gegen die
pandemie ist für ihn das impfen der
beste schutz vor umgekommen ist eine
booster impfung und deshalb ist es gut
dass wir unser ziel dass wir zuletzt
gesetzt hatten des weihnachten 30
millionen impfungen zu erreichen auch
tatsächlich erreicht haben und das ist
genauso gut das bier kalt sich am
nächsten ziel arbeiten nämlich bis zum
ende dieses monats die nächsten 30 mio
booster impfung zu organisieren 2g plus
ist eines der neuen instrumente von dem
sich der gipfel sinkende
infektionszahlen erhofft doch bei
einigen ländern gibt es auch nach der
runde unterschiedliche auffassungen ob
dieses instrument wirklich wirkt
deswegen sind wir skeptisch ob zweige
plus in der normalen castro jenseits von
disco jenen satz und was sinnvoll ist
ich habe den gesundheitsminister gebeten
zu prüfen ob das aus unserer sicht
wirklich notwendig ist wir sind das sehr
sehr zurückhaltend und skeptisch
einigkeit dagegen beim thema quarantäne
regelungen die neufassung wird
einstimmig begrüßt und auch die
sofortige auszahlung von
wirtschaftshilfen an betroffene betriebe
durch den bund kommt bei den ländern gut
an der positive punkt für heute ist dass
die wirtschaftshilfen um die wir gebeten
hatten als wir ja in thüringen schon
härte in den in die
abstandsregelung mussten als die
weihnachtsmärkte geschlossen werden
mussten dass diese wirtschaftshilfen ab
heute freigeschaltet sind ich finde das
ist gut und wichtig zu wissen weniger
gut finden die unionsgeführten länder
dass die bundesregierung sich weigert
die epidemische notlage von nationaler
tragweite wieder einzuführen dies sei
voraussetzung um die pandemie effektiv
zu bekämpfen dazu gehöre übrigens auch
eine allgemeine impfpflicht
es darf nicht das gefühl entstehen dass
bei dieser zentralen frage für die
pandemie bekämpfung taktiert wird
politik musste auch verlässlich sein
länder gehen davon aus dass bald ein
zeitplan für das weitere vorgehen zur
einführung einer allgemeinen impfpflicht
vorliegen wird ich setze mich aktiv
dafür ein dass es dazu kommt keine drei
stunden hat die runde getagt der kampf
gegen die pandemie dauer die heute
beschlossenen maßnahmen müssen jetzt
ihre praxistauglichkeit beweisen nächste
politische überprüfung ist der 24 januar
dann tagt die runde nämlich wieder
und alaba nati in berlin welches signal
geht von dieser konferenz aus eigentlich
sind gleich zwei signale das erste
lautet omikron verändert die lage bleibt
aber eine gefahr für die kritische
infrastruktur in deutschland und die
zweite botschaft lautet die länder und
der bund neben diese gefahr so ernst
dass sie gemeinsam reagieren wollen und
geschlossen reagieren wollen deswegen
haben wir heute in der kommunikation
nach der runde vor allem eine betonung
der gemeinsamen maßnahmen gehört und die
streitpunkte die es gab die die union
auch noch einmal angesprochen hatte
nämlich wie der einführung der
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
und ein zeitplan für die impfpflicht die
geplante die blieben in der
kommunikation weitestgehend außen vor
aber so ganz einig ist man sich dann
doch nicht denn schon scheren ja die
ersten ministerpräsidenten wieder aus ja
das stimmt die kakophonie ist nicht so
groß wie wir es bei anderen
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen in der
vergangenheit schon erlebt haben aber
vor allem das was der ministerpräsident
von sachsen-anhalt reiner haseloff
gesagt hat nämlich dass sein bundesland
erst einmal nicht auf zweig plus bei
gastronomie setzen will das dürfte die
bundesregierung nicht erfreuen denn das
ist eben ein ausscheren aus dieser
gemeinsamen haltung und das stört ein
wenig das geschlossene signal was man da
aussenden wollte der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat ja darauf
gesetzt mit gemeinsamen maßnahmen die
pandemie hier jetzt anzugehen und zu
bekämpfen das ist ihm jetzt im ersten
schritt nicht gelungen aufgrund dieser
abweichenden stimme dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus berlin chacón talabani
wir haben es gehört verkürzte quarantäne
zeiten sollen verhindern dass omikron
das öffentliche leben lahm legt vor
allem in der kritischen infrastruktur
will man personal engpässe vermeiden
also in kliniken bei energieversorgern
oder der müllabfuhr wie die sich
vorbereiten sagt zeigt malin ihlau in
der medizinischen hochschule in hannover
sieht man sich für den ernstfall gut
gerüstet seit beginn der pandemie wurden
notfallpläne erarbeitet doch falls noch
mehr pflegepersonal ausfallen sollte
während der omicron welle reagiert man
erleichtert über lockerungen der
quarantäne regelungen für medizinisches
personal
ich denke es ist richtig sinnvoll die
quarantäne zweiten jetzt zu verkürzen
wir wissen über die omikron variante
mehr als wir noch vor vier fünf wochen
wussten wir wissen aber auch dass sie
jetzt allmählich oberhand gewinnt und
wir müssen vorkehrungen treffen damit
das land nach wie vor funktionsfähig wie
gut sind die länder auf mögliche
personalengpässe vorbereitet vor allem
in sensiblen bereichen wie hier im
lagezentrum der polizei wo der
digitalfunk in ganz niedersachsen
überwacht wird wir haben besondere
vorkehrungen getroffen dass wir mit a
und b stehen arbeiten in der polizei
sprich dadurch kontakte vermeiden in den
dienststellen viel mit homeoffice
agieren dort wo es möglich ist noch gibt
es keinen grund zur sorge heißt es auch
beim katastrophenschutz
es mag sein dass es
infrastrukturbereiche gibt wo eben
personalausfälle vielleicht mal dazu
führen dass das ein oder andere system
sich etwas verzögert zum beispiel in der
logistik aber gerade ich sage mal die
ganze system reiche wenn wir zum
beispiel die wasserversorgung über die
strom und gasversorgung sprechen das ist
wirklich bereiche die exzellent
aufgestellt bei den stadtwerken in
münchen will man im notfall sogar
mitarbeiter der energie und
wasserversorgung k sanieren
und an dieser stelle der blick auf die
korona zahlen die weiter steigen nach
angaben des robert koch instituts gab es
binnen 24 stunden 56
1335 neuinfektionen das sind 15 1095
mehr als vor einer woche außerdem kamen
264 todesfälle innerhalb eines tages
dazu die sieben tage incidents steigt
auf 303,4 ebenso mit 62
1974 die zahl der insgesamt
nachgewiesenen omikron fälle ein zuwachs
von 22 prozent im vergleich zum vortag
gleich nach uns gibt's ein zdf spezial
zu den bund länder beschlossen im
interview dazu gesundheitsminister
lauterbach alles wichtige zu den neuen
corona maßnahmen haben wir für sie
online und in der zdf- heute eher kurz
und knapp zusammengefasst
zur krise in kasachstan dort hat
präsident tokarev seinen soldaten im
fall weiterer unruhen einen schießbefehl
erteilt seit tagen trifft in dem land
gewalt auf gegen gewalt vor allem in der
millionen stadt almaty
bewaffnete demonstrierende stehen
polizei und armee gegenüber
verhandlungen schließt tokarev aus wer
sich nicht ergibt wird zerstört sagt er
in seiner fernsehansprache
axel sturm
6 checkpoints haben sie eingerichtet
rund um die hauptstadt nur sultan
während menschen im ganzen land
versuchen an bargeld zu kommen während
noch in der nacht der tv-sender mir
brennt während die verwüstung
allgegenwärtig ist spricht der präsident
davon dass die verfassungsmäßige ordnung
wieder hergestellt sei und sagt
gleichzeitig
terroristen beschädigen weiterhin staats
und privateigentum und setzten
waffengewalt gegen bürger ein ich habe
den strafverfolgungsbehörden und der
armee den befehl gegeben ohne vorwarnung
das feuer zu eröffnen
die unruhen seien aus dem ausland
registriert wird weiter verkündet allein
die metropole am marti sei von 20.000
sogenannten banditen angegriffen worden
so wird der ruf nach den russischen
soldaten gerechtfertigt die die gefahr
abwehren sollen und deren präsenz in
kasachstan für die kameras akribisch
inszeniert wird
eigentlich ist es ein konflikt der
bürger mit ihren herrschern jetzt aber
gibt es einen neuen aspekt intervention
von außen die regierung hat die
ausländischen soldaten eingeladen die
demos waren ausgebrochen wegen eines
wiederholten massiven preisanstiegs beim
flüssiggas im hintergrund aber spielt
unzufriedenheit vor allem über
jahrzehnte langen wirtschaftlichen und
gesellschaftlichen stillstand über
repressionen russland will für ruhe
sorgen im nachbarland sicherlich nicht
uneigennützig
fragen wir nach in moskau und brüssel
zuerst zur fünftel gar welche
informationen bekommen sie aktuell aus
kasachstan
also aktuell interessant ist vor allem
auch da hinzuschauen wo besonders lautes
schweigen herrscht denn seit beginn der
proteste ist kasachstan sex präsident
von der bildfläche verschwunden dabei
galt nasarbajew eigentlich bislang als
der eigentlich starke mann im land trotz
seinem rücktritt vor zwei jahren hat der
autokrat weiter die geschicke casas tanz
gelenkt sein nachfolger im amt präsident
türkei elf galt eigentlich mehr oder
weniger nur als sein erfüllungsgehilfe
jetzt also ist unklar wo sich nasarbajew
aufhält und er schweigt zumindest
öffentlich während total auf ebendiesen
schießbefehl erteilt und russische
truppen ins land einlädt wann wo und vor
allem in welcher rolle nasarbajew wieder
auftaucht das wird tiefere einblicke
geben in das was in kasachstan hinter
den kulissen vor sich geht
gehen wir zu florian neuer nach brüssel
dort gab es heute eine video-konferenz
der nato-außenminister florian wie
wertet die nato das eingreifen russland
sind kasachstan
diese krise in kasachstan passt schlecht
ins bild dass man hier von russischer
geopolitik derzeit hat das russland eben
notfalls auch mit militärischer gewalt
das verteidigt was man als die eigene
einflusssphäre betrachtet
das gilt eben aktuell für kasachstan
aber es gilt eben vielleicht auch für
die ukraine an deren grenze die nato
weiterhin einen ungebremsten russischen
truppenaufmarsch beobachtet und über all
das wird man in den nächsten tagen auf
verschiedenen ebenen mit russland direkt
verhandeln das problem dabei ist nur
dass russland für diesen dialog
forderungen erhebt die aus sicht der
nato völlig inakzeptabel sind etwa den
abzug von nato soldaten aus osteuropa
oder den verzicht auf eine weitere ost
erweiterung der nato und so sagte der
nato-generalsekretär hier heute abend in
brüssel man müsse sich auch darauf
vorbereiten dass dieser diplomatische
weg möglicherweise scheitert
dankeschön nach brüssel und moskau für
begab und florian mayer
zurück nach deutschland in mecklenburg
vorpommern bangen tausende menschen um
ihren job die zukunft der mv werften
steht auf der kippe die löhne für
dezember hat der asiatische eigentümer
bisher nicht gezahlt entsprechend
aufgeladen war die stimmung auf der
betriebsversammlung heute mit wut aber
auch mit angst ob und wie es weitergeht
sabah die lage spitzt sich weiter zu auf
der werft in wismar auch nach der
betriebsversammlung am mittag weiter
ungewissheit
[Musik]
und am montag werden wir alle wieder auf
der matte stehen und weiter hoffentlich
am schiff bauen können im dock die
global dream ein kreuzfahrtriese rund 70
prozent sind fertiggestellt sein
weiterbau steht auf messers schneide
durch finanzlücken beim asiatischen
mutterkonzern gm droht die insolvenz
der investor wollte auf den werften im
nordosten schiffe bauen für mehr
passagiere als je zuvor neuland für den
konzern mit sitz in hongkong der sein
geld vor allem mit kreuzfahrten und
kasinos verdient bisher in der pandemie
in einen schlingerkurs geriet nur mit
hilfe von bund und land konnte der
prototyp bisher weiter gebaut werden 301
millionen euro gab allein mecklenburg
vorpommern als bürgschaften bund und
land wollen mehr als 600 millionen
weitere kredite nur dann geben wenn sich
genthin beteiligt bislang mauern die
asiaten der handel mit ihren aktien an
der hongkonger börse wurde vorläufig
ausgesetzt
das wird heute noch ein gespräch geben
auf oberste regierungsebene
das ist für mich ein zeichen und wir
werden abwarten müssen wie sich die
weitere entwicklung übers wochenende
dann zeigt am montag werden wir dann
wissen kommen wir wieder zurück dass wir
da schon weiter bauen können die
hoffnung ist groß dass dann auch die
löhne gezahlt werden können das hätte
eigentlich heute geschehen müssen das
baggern im nordosten geht weiter
er war ein ganz großer in hollywood
sidney portier läutete als erster
schwarzer filmstar eine neue ära ein
gewann als erster afroamerikaner einen
oscar er galt als eher sanfter rebell
der buchstäblich vom tellerwäscher zum
millionär wurde und vater von sechs
töchtern mit 94 ist er in los angeles
gestorben hier in kelheim hat
sidney partie trifft nelson mandela ein
schauspieler begegnet dem original
seiner lieblingsrolle das sei für ihn
großartig gewesen sein partie die
persönlichkeit mandelas zeigen zu dürfen
zwei charaktere die offenbar gut
harmonieren auch body kämpfte für
bürgerrechte 1963 reihte er sich eine
die amerikanische bewegung die für die
gleichberechtigung der
afro-amerikanischen minderheit auf die
straße ging im gleichen die harte partie
mit lilien auf dem felde filmgeschichte
geschrieben als erster schwarzer
hauptdarsteller älter 1964 den
begehrtesten preis der branche in oscar
den baum journey to the moment
[Musik]
er blieb einer der begehrtesten
schauspieler hollywood eine legende zu
lebzeiten
und er war auch ein diplomat neben der
amerikanischen hat er auch die
staatsangehörigkeit seiner heimat
bahamas und 997 wurde ihm eine besondere
ehre zuteil unsere botschafter der
karibikinsel in japan als einfacher
bauernsohn brachte sporty zum
umschwärmten gast im weißen haus als
vollblut schauspieler
[Applaus]
in erinnerung bleiben als darsteller und
beharrlicher kämpfer vorbild für viele
nicht nur in den usa
absolut jetzt sport handball die
deutschen handballer hat heute das erste
von zwei testspielen vor dem start der
europameisterschaft in einer woche der
gegner die schweiz das team von alfred
gislason wurde neu formiert und gewann
mit 30 zu 26 ein sieg fürs
selbstvertrauen junge spieler wie julian
köster ebenso erleichtert wie alte hasen
vom schlage eines patrick wiencek nach
den em absagen vieler stammspieler sid
bundestrainer kießler und durchaus
brauchbare ansätze der neu ins team
gespülten akteure gegen die nicht für
die em qualifizierte aber gut
eingespielte mannschaft der schweiz
gelingen wie hier durch casting
sehenswerte treffer wenig überraschend
jedoch auch solche missverständnisse die
die eidgenossen lange im spiel halten am
ende aber ein klarer sieg mit vier
treffern differenz ein erfolg der dem
team gut tut vom letzten test am sonntag
gegen olympiasieger frankreich
axel jung ist beim skeleton weltcup in
winterberg auf den zweiten rang gefahren
ebenso wie jacqueline learning bei den
frauen die auf ihrer heimbahn ihr
bislang bestes ergebnis in dieser saison
erzielte nur 24 hundertstel hinter der
siegreichen
kimberly boss
wintersport premieren weil die firma der
erste mixed weltcup wettbewerb der
nordischen kombinierer das deutsche team
wurde dritter in einem spannenden
wettkampf
als vierter nach dem springen in die
leute gestartet ist für das deutsche
mixed ihm sogar mehr möglich startläufer
jakob lange holt einen rückstand von 41
sekunden auf und übergibt anziehen die
harsch die sich an platz zwei heran
kämpfte jenny nowak schließt dann sogar
zur führenden auf am ende sicher terence
weber bei der mixed team premiere den
dritten platz für deutschland der erste
sieg in diesem wettbewerb geht an den
top favorit norwegen vor österreich
zum biathlon-weltcup in oberhof während
die deutschen frauen eher enttäuschten
zeigten die männer eine gute leistung
bei einem 10 kilometer sprint verpasste
johannes kühn das podium nach zwei
schießfehlern nur knapp und wurde
vierter sein teamkollege roman rees
fünfter sieger der russe alexander vogel
auf
das was vom sport dankeschön und fern
zum schluss noch was fürs herz ein
rührendes wiedersehen acht jahre nach
dem kessel aus einem vorgarten in
südengland gestohlen wurde hat die
polizei die hündin zu ihrer familie
zurück gebracht die beamten hatten das
tier bei der suche nach einem anderen
gestohlenen hund gefunden herrchen und
frauchen sind überglücklich der
cockerspaniel mopsfidel und tat
dreifachen nachwuchs mitgebracht
heute nacht gibt es im südwesten viel
schnee was das wetter am wochenende
sonst noch bringt sagt gleich katja
hornuf marietta slomka ist nachher
gleich zweimal ran um kurz vor 10 in
einem kurzen heute-journal spezial und
dann nochmal gegen
23.30 ausführlicher wir wünschen ihnen
ein schönes wochenende alles gute und
erinnern noch mal an das zdf spezial
dass jetzt gleich kommt auf wiedersehen
das morgen
[Musik]
guten abend kaum ist das eine schnee und
regen nach osten abgezogen kommt schon
gleich das nächste hinterher das sieht
heute nacht über die mitte und den süden
deutschlands und morgen nachmittag kommt
schon wieder neuer schnee und regen von
westen heran heute nach also fällt noch
schnee und schneeregen hier in der
osthälfte dann kommt das neue tief das
bringt auch gewitter mit und in den
mittelgebirgen zwei bis zehn zentimeter
neuschnee und diese zentimeter neuschnee
bleiben auch liegen denn die
temperaturen sinken auf werte zwischen
plus ein und minus sieben grad
gefährlich glatt wird also auf den
straßen morgen über tag wird es dann
milder dann liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen minus ein
und plus 6 grad und am vormittag schneit
es dann noch hier am alpenrand und auch
richtung thüringen dann das erstmal ganz
freundlich das wird sich aber bald
ändern denn schon am nachmittag kommen
mit einem stürmischen südwind neue
schnee und regen wolken von westen heran
und der sonntag bringt dann hier im
thüringer wald und auch im erzgebirge
bis zu 20 zentimeter neuschnee
hin und wieder sind sogar kurze graupel
gewitter möglich und die sonne sehen sie
wirklich nur ganz selten wenn dann wohl
allenfalls mal an der ostseeküste
schönen abend